[Musique]
ouis très bien notre invité ce matin
c'est Thierry Marx bonjour merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation Thierry ma vous êtes chef
étoilé on n présente plus président de
l'UMI l'Union des métiers et des
industries de l'hôtellerie on est ravi
de vous recevoir ce matin on va
évidemment revenir sur cette colère des
agriculteurs qui s'est exprimé ces
derniers jours comment vous expliquez
cet embrasement est-ce qu'il vous a
surpris ou est-ce que le feu couvé
depuis longtemps j'ai j'ai envie de vous
vous répondre que ça ne m'a pas surpris
et je pense que ça n'a pas surpris les
gens de ma génération c'est pas
conjoncturel c'est structurel on voit
bien qu'on a une difficulté avec de
projeter notre politique agricole et euh
et en même temps de de considérer que le
modèle qu'on avait là sous les yeux de
cette crise agricole montre bien qu'il y
a un problème en France avec toutes ces
normes et toute cette complexité parce
que ce sont des agriculteurs ce sont nos
paysans mais ça n'est pas moins des
entreprises et toutes les entreprises
aujourd'hui en France rencontrent un
certain nombre de difficultés sur qui
sont mis en place sur ces normes et sur
notre capacité à nous développer ouais
on va revenir évidemment sur sur ces
difficultés et sur le fond parmi les
motifs d'inquiétude et de colère il y a
la question de la juste rémunération des
agriculteurs qui sont mal rémunérés
est-ce que ils sont en position de
faiblesse aujourd'hui dans les rapports
de force entre agriculteur industriel
grand distri champ oui son position de
faiblesse parce qu'on a laissé croire
dans cette théorie du lowcost du tout
pas cher espèce de rouleau compresseur
comme ça qui date des années en gros des
années 70 de laisser croire que la
variable d'ajustement du pouvoir d'achat
pouvait être l'alimentation c'est pas
possible quand vous écraser les prix
vous écrasz les marges de quelqu'un et
notamment celle de l'agriculteur donc il
y a des mécanismes à mettre en place moi
je défends depuis un certain nombre
d'anné l'idée de cette association par
exemple bleu blanqueœur qui est capable
de mesurer sa qualité des sols bien-être
animal et de définir ce que c'est qu'un
bon produit son impact social son impact
environnemental et son impact
nutritionnel mais un bon produit doit
permettre à l'agriculteur 1 de se
rémunérer de de faire suffisamment de
revenus pour pouvoir investir dans
l'impact environnemental qu' qui doit se
mettre en place on est tous conscient de
cela mais à un moment donné il faut
arrêter de faire de la variable
d'ajustement l'alimentation c'est pas le
sujet il faut faire monter les minimas
sociaux il faut que les gens gagnent
mieux leur vie mais définir ce qu'est un
bon produit et être capable de mesurer
ce que un bon produit son impact social
environnemental et nutritionnel ça ça
doit être très important de le mesurer
est-ce que du coup il y a pas un
paradoxe chez les consommateurs alors
évidemment il y a il y a ceux qui sont à
l'euro près au centimes près et qui ne
peuvent pas payer plus cher mais il y a
aussi ceux qui pourraient payer quelques
centimes plus chers leurs produits
alimentaires et et qui ne le font pas
mais mais c'est c'est vrai c'est un
constat vous avez parfaitement raison on
a une fracture sociale qui est de plus
en plus du qui est de plus en plus
inflammable et de de découvrir que
finalement nous avions alimentation à
deux vitesses une alimentation pour ceux
qui ont un reste à vivre suffisant qui
peuvent comprendre ce qu'ils doivent
acheter pour mieux se nourrir et ceux
qui ont reste à vivre insuffisant et qui
hélas se contentent de produits peu
chers et des fois ultra transformés qui
nuise globalement à la santé donc au
coût de la santé publique mais ça veut
dire qu'il faut dire au consommateur
qu'il a aussi une responsabilité dans la
survie de de nos agriculteurs mais bien
sûr dans pouvoir d'achat il y a pouvoir
il y a pouvoir de non il à pouvoir de
mieux gérer un petit peu son panier mais
en même temps quand vous êtes dans
l'urgence et dans ce sentiment
d'ailleurs ce que nous ont bien
démontrer les agriculteurs ce sentiment
de déclassement de ne pas pouvoir avoir
pareil que les autres il y a un vrai
sentiment d'injustice donc on peut pas
être donneur de leçon en disant vous
mangez pas bien parce que vous avez pas
suffisamment d'argent encore une fois
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette société
qui produit autant d'exclusion la parole
de Coluche il y a 40 ans voyez 39 ans
des Restos du cœur et je parlais avec le
le président des des des restaux du cœur
il y a quelques temps et on dit
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette machine à
exclusion qui s'est mis en en place
depuis des annéesù on narrive plus à
faire en sorte que ces fractures
sociales diminuent ouais il y a a il y a
un retour un peu vers le circuit court
depuis cette colère agricole mais
c'était aussi le cas pendant la crise
covid où les Français sont revenus vers
des circuits courts et puis ils sont
revenus à leurs habitudes de
consommation traditionnelle c'est-à-dire
aller plutôt dans les grandes surfaces
vous craignez que ce soit un nouveau le
cas là mais c'est déjà le nouveau le cas
c'est qu'on avait on s'était promis une
sortie du covid avec une une
responsabilité environnementale une
responsabilité sociale on était tous
très convaincus que c'était ça où nous
allions mourir et cetera cette peur
finalement mentomoris souviens-toi que
tu es un mortel qui nous est revenu en
pleine figure on a eu très très peur de
cela et finalement qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé à la sortie du covid on a vu la
guerre des prix qui pouvait être le
moins cher comment on allait pouvoir
mesurer qui était le moins cher et cette
inflation qui pèse encore une fois sur
les ménages lié à l'alimentation il y a
un sujet de fond qui est la rémunération
comment les gens peuvent mieux gagner
leur vie pour pouvoir avoir le choix
d'une alimentation beaucoup plus saine
et de rémunérer justement à la juste
valeur les agriculteurs est-ce que pu
que vous parlez de rémunération il y a
par exemple éc chutier le président des
républicains qui propose que les
agriculteurs a un salaire minimum 2500 €
netes est-ce que c'est ce qu'ils
attendent les agriculteurs pour vous qui
les côtoyez tous les jours mais je je
crois pas moi ça fait 20 ans que je
côtoie les agriculteur au travers de de
de bleu blanqueur et je vois bien que ce
sont des chefs d'entreprise aussi qui
investissent qui veulent gagner leur vie
ils ne sont pas là à demander l'omone en
permanence aucun chef d'entreprise en
France ne demande l'omone on veut vivre
du travail de l'effort qui est fait et
les agriculteurs c'est on éclaire le
sensible quand on parle d'agriculteurs
on parle de notre alimentation et il est
vrai qu'il faut mettre tout le monde en
face de ces responsabilités et
effectivement vous l'avez dit le
consommateur qui par moment est dans
l'ambigué du tout pas cher il y a aussi
la question de notre souveraineté
alimentaire on importe 70 % du poisson
qu'on consomme 50 % de nos fruit et
légumes 50 % de notre volaille comment
aujourd'hui on peut résoudre cette
équation et bien c'est-à-dire que à mon
avis encore une fois mon âme l'avis je
suis pas un spécialiste de l'agriculture
mais il faut être capable de tracer les
choses les Anglais disent forcter faire
des prévisions travailler mesurer les
choses pour remettre une politique
agricole pour les 10 prochaines années
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans un tel débat de tel débat d'idées
qu'on oppose des contraires et on oppose
les uns contre les autres or qu'on est
dans une situation aujourd'hui où il
faut trouver des solutions pas chercher
que des coupables donc bien sûr que l'
l'industrie de
l'alimentation un rôle à jouer que la
grande distribution a un rôle à jouer et
que le monde agricole a un rôle à jouer
mais c'est une mécanique positive
d'aller de l'avant pour que tout le
monde puisse équilibrer tout ça mais il
faut avoir une politique sur du long
terme c'est très difficile pour un homme
politique ou des gens élus aujourd'hui
d'avoir une politique de long terme vu
qu'on oppose que des contraires en
permanence alors qu'on on se refuse à
trouver des solutions sur du durable
quand Gabriel Attal dit qu'il veut
inscrire la souveraineté alimentaire
dans la loi est-ce que pour vous ça
laisse augurer d'une politique sur le
long terme mais mais moi j'entends et je
je souscris maintenant il va falloir que
nos hommes et femmes politiques nous
expliquent comment ils peuvent mettre
des choses en pratique sur du long terme
voyez ce qui m'a ce qui a étonné
beaucoup les citoyens c'est qu'on parle
de la loi égalim c'est une bonne loi
finalement on peut la on peut
l'améliorer elle a été améliorée on
l'entend et on découvre là qu'il va
falloir maintenant renforcer des
contrôles pour faire appliquer la loi à
quoi sert de faire voter des lois si
elles ne sont pas appliquées voyez c'est
ces mécanismes là que le citoyen et je
suis a du mal à comprendre se dire mais
pourquoi on en arrive là pourquoi on
arrive à une situation de crise donc de
blocage pour définir que maintenant il
va falloir faire appliquer la loi alors
que c là cette loi elle a quand même
quelques années maintenant c'est
complexé c'est là où par moment le
citoyen regarde le monde politique le
monde des élus avec un regard un petit
peu mais de d'incompréhension en disant
mais si on a voté ces lois si nous
sommes d'accord pour ces lois alors
pourquoi ne sont-elles pas appliquées il
y a aussi la question vous en parlez
tout à l'heure en parlant de complexité
la question des normes et du trop de
normes dont se prent dont se plaignent
les agriculteurs est-ce que la
simplification des normes qui a été
lancé par gabrielal ça vous paraît la
bonne réponse mais la simplification
deses oui ça me paraît une bonne réponse
moi ce qui m'inquiète toujours c'est
qu'il y a des donneurs de leçon qui
viennent vous imposer des normes sans
études d'impact donc vous avez
l'interdiction euh d'un produit
phytosanitaire et on l'entend que ce
soit pas bon pour la santé mais on
remplace pas rien mais par contre les
autres ont le droit de vous prendre vous
vendre ces produits avec les mêmes
produits il y a une un sentiment
d'injustice pour l'agriculteur
aujourd'hui qui est pas qui est pas
consevableonisation dans toute l'Europe
exactement si on fait des normes s'il y
a des normes qui sont euh applicables il
faut au moins qu'elles aient des études
d'impact qu'on les vérifie et qu'avec
ces études d'impact on se dise oui on va
pouvoir faire une transition vous savez
l'écologie pour moi j'ai toujours vu ça
comme un sachet de thé
un bol d'eau chaude un sachet de thé
quand ça devient mère on retire on
rajoute on retire ça doit diffuser en
permanence dans notre ctidien l'idée
qu'il va falloir avoir une
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale mais dès lors vous êtes
dans espèce de jusqu'au bouhisme et
d'une espèce de dictature qui vient
imposer à des personnes de de ne pas
leur reconnaître le droit deux même
d'être des gens liés à l'écologie j'ai
jamais vu un agriculteur qui était
contre la planète moi j'ai jamais vu ça
donc à un moment donné et on oublie de
dire souvent d'abord un qu' y a des
solutions qui marchent dans
l'agriculture j'ai cité l'association
bleu blanqueur mais il y a aussi des
modèles où la science est venue apporter
de l'aide pour limiter les produits
phytosanitaires vous savez j'étais très
critique à une époque de ce qui pouvait
se passer dans la bosse sur les blé CSA
puis un jour il y a un agriculteur qui
est venu me montrer qui m'a fait visiter
son exploitation m' dit je soigne les
plantes quasiment au pied par pied donc
je je traite qu'une plante si elle a la
maladie et cetera et cetera doncz des
choses qui sont et c'est vrai que par
moment les agriculteurs ne sont sont pas
forcément les meilleurs communicquants
non plus donc il a fallu attendre cette
situation de crise or qu'encore une fois
je pense que c'est pas conjoncturel mais
structurel et il faut laisser il faut
travailler avec le monde agricole pour
aller je dis pas en douceur il faut
aller mesurer cet impact social et les
raison de retirer un peu le sachet de
thé au moins pendant oui quand ça devent
merre là il y avait une dose d'amertume
qui était plus supportable sur le le
modèle agricole est-ce que on peut se
passer d'un modèle agricole
productiviste alors qu'on disait tout à
l'heure il y a énormément de nos
produits qui sont importés non on peut
pas se passer à mon avis d'un d'un
modèle agricole productiviste mais
encore une fois il va falloir comprendre
comment le mettre en place et encore une
fois il y a des choses qui fonctionnent
il faut le dire nous on va en parler
avec bleu blanc cœur au salon de
l'agriculture c'est un salon que j'adore
parce qu'il y a une vraie rencontre avec
un vrai public un vrai monde agricole et
le citoyen et donc le consommateur qui
doit redevenir aussi ce consommateur un
peu un mangeur mais à un moment donné il
faut aussi laisser faire les
agriculteurs quand on parle d'AGR
foresterie bien ils y sont ils y
viennent moins de traitement ils y
viennent exactement mais il faut
accpagner tout ça mais à un moment donné
de croire que quelqu'un qui serait
cheveux gras etpatogaz qui viendrait
définir que la perma culture est la
seule et unique solution et bien non ce
sera pas la seule et unique solution
c'est une multitude de solutions pour
notre souveraineté alimentaire sauf que
selon un rapport du Sénat notre surface
agricole a diminué notre nombre
d'exploitants agricooles a diminué on le
sait il y a un gros problème de
renouvellement des générations notamment
dans les 10 ans à venir est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes inquiet pour
l'avenir de l'agriculture française mais
moi je suis inquiet surtout
pour lariculture française parce que
c'est dans la transmission aussi des des
entreprises il y a un vrai sujet espèce
on va venir sur une transmission d'une
exploitation l'état vient prélever et
rançonner un certain nombre de choses où
les gens se retrouvent encore une fois
surendetté rien que pour reprendre
l'exploitation familiale c'est pas là
aussi il faut déranger des cercles et
faire bouger les choses là-dessus ce qui
est vrai pour l'agriculteur est vrai
aussi pour le restaurateur et l'hôtelier
donc il faut aussi comprendre que tout
ce qui a été mis en place en France par
des principes de précaution des fois à
étage finalement aujourd'hui ça ne
fonctionne plus donc il faut trouver des
solutions justement on va parler de la
restauration et de l'hôtellerie
puisqu'on le disait vous êtes président
de l'Union des métiers et des industries
de l'hôtellerie comment se porte
aujourd'hui le secteur il c'est un
secteur en zone de turbulence parce que
je pourrais prendre les mêmes mots et
les mêmes effets que vous avez parlé du
monde agricole et les ramener dans le
monde de l'hôtellerie restauration coût
de production qui ont beaucoup augmenté
15 ou 20 % de votre assiette est liée au
coût de l'énergie coût des matières
premières a largement augmenté le coût
des salaires aussi a largement augmenté
donc je pour beaucoup de modèles
économiques de notre secteur d'activité
et bien ça devient très très compliqué
le modèle économique ne tient plus par
moment 7000 entreprise en 2023 ont
déposé le bilan donc c'est une une un
chiffon rouge qui a agité la Banque de
France mais il faut en tenir compte et
puis le monde qui change le président de
la République a parlé de ce monde qui
change ce monde qui s'est digitalisé
l'ubérisation est arrivé on voit bien
que nos amis hôteliers sur ce digital
market act on voit bien que les
plateformes viennent prendre entre le
client et euh le l'hôtelier 18 entre 15
et 18 % de marge que n'a plus l'ôutelier
donc il y a un monde qui change il faut
que l'État soit en capacité l'Europe de
réguler tout ça parce que sinon c'est
elle est suffisamment aujourd'hui je
pense pas qu'elle soit suffisamment
assez forte et pas suffisamment alertée
des risques que ça représente quand vous
prenez simplement l'ubérisation du
travail il y a un sujet quid de notre
modèle social aujourd'hui on voit bien
que les gens ne vivent plus suffisamment
avec leur salaire leur salaire donc ils
choisissent l'auto-entrepreneurat on
peut entendre aujourd'hui c'est une
vraie uérisation du travail qui
s'installe on voit bien que dans la
restauration ça peut être condamnable
mais ça ne l'est plus vraiment donc il y
a une ambigué là-dessus et va falloir
que l'État travaille sur cette
régulation de ce monde qui subérise et
qui à mon avis est un capitalisme
beaucoup plus violent que ce qu'on a
connu au 20e siècle il y a aussi est-ce
qu'il y a aussi un changement dans le
rapport des des Français au travail qui
se fait d'autant plus sentir dans vos
métiers qui sont des métiers difficiles
avec des horaires décalés avec des
contraintes particulières est-ce que
pour vous c'est ce qui explique
notamment les difficultés de recrutement
je je vais essayer de de répondre en
plusieurs temps c'est c'est pas des
métiers plus difficiles que d'autres si
vous êtes agent de nuit dans la sécurité
dans une plateforme logistique vous avez
les mêmes les mêmes contraintes il faut
que les gens gagnent leur vie avec il
faut s'interroger pourquoi le travail
n'imancipe pas simplement le travail de
l'hôtellerie restauration dans
l'ensemble des métiers on voit bien que
les gens aujourd'hui n'arrivent plus
avec leur salaire à vivre et à projeter
leur vie au travers de leur rémunération
c'est un sujet sur tous les secteurs
d'activité nous avons augmenté les
salaires de 16 % à la sortie du covid
croyez-moi ça a pas été simple pour
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises mais
nous l'avons fait on a plutôt bien
réussi cela mais malgré tout on a des
gens et pas simplement des jeunes
d'ailleurs qui nous disent je ne veux
plus avoir un rapport sacrificiel au
travail je veux une replanification de
mon travail je veux une activité
différente donc il se tourne par moment
vers l'ubérisation du travail qui leur
permet d'avoir une flexibilité ça veut
dire quoi si on ne fait pas attention à
ça quit du modèle social français nous
avons des gens aujourd'hui dans des
entreprises qui sont ubérisés et qui
n'ont aucune couverture sociale sur les
difficultés de recrutement dans dans
votre secteur et est-ce que sur la loi
immigration et notamment cette fameuse
ce fameux article dont on a beaucoup
parlé sur la régularisation des
travailleurs étrangers dans les métiers
en tension est-ce que pour vous ça va
vous aider bah c'est-à-dire que oui ça
aurait pu nous aider mais c'est pas le
sujet nous le sujet il est déjà de
remettre un ensemble de de personnes
dans un projet métier pour qu'il
reviennent au travail ça c'est le
travail de la formation professionnelle
et de l'accessibilité à la formation
professionnelle après sur cette métier
en tension nous ne sommes pas métier en
tension aspect comptable des choses mais
nous ne sommes pas encore mé enention et
la loi immigration pourrait nous
permettre pour des personnes qui sont là
depuis longtemps qui n'ont jamais posé
de problème à notre République française
qui travaillent dans nos métiers qui se
sont épanouis dans métiers qui font qui
ont fait le rap à un moment donné de
pouvoir régular de régulariser ces
personnes c'était ça ce que nous
attendions un petit peu de la loi
immigration c'était on personne n'osait
en parler et notamment le le monde de
l'entreprise ne sait pas dire oui il
faut avoir une réponse claire sur la
immigration oui il y a des gens qui sont
sur le sol français qui ne pose aucun
problème et qui travaille dans notre
secteur d'activité pourquoi ne pas les
régulariser pas all assez loin cette loi
pour vous elle est pas non je pense
qu'on on n'arrive pas à poser le débat
vous voyez bien qu'à l'Assemblée on
oppose des contraire mais on ne pose pas
le débat trouver une solution sur la
immigration c'est qu'à un moment donné
il faut avoir un débat apaisé et il y a
pas de débat apaisé tant qu'il y a pas
de débat apaisé vous ne pouvez pas
trouver une solution vous ne trouvez que
des coupables vous avez créé en 2012 des
écoles cuisine mode d'emploi vous en
avez 10 aujourd'hui quel bilan
faites-vous un bilan heureux a plus plus
de 5000 personnes qui ont été formé
formé 92 % de retour dans un projet
métier donc ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui nous tient à cœur est-ce que
ça a été facile non est-ce que c'est
toujours compliqué oui parce que
effectivement tous les présidents
successifs que nous avons pu rencontrer
tous les ministres que nous avons pu
c'est formidable vous avez un taux
absolument incroyable mais en même temps
on bloque des fois sur des soucis
administratifs pour valider financer un
certain nombre de trop de paperasse trop
de cont trop c'estàd que aujourd'hui
quand vous montez une école vous avez
déjà quatre personnes qui vont être
dédiées uniquement à
l'administration et ça c'est beaucoup
trop coûteux c'estàd et quand vous avez
entendu Gabriel Attal dire il faut
débureaucratiser tout
ça on l'a entendu là-dessus il faut desb
CRR tout ça mais est-ce qu'on sait le
faire est-ce que il faudra avoir un
temps long pour débloquer tout ça et
puis quand il a parlé de
desmicardisé on a trouvé ça intéressant
bien que le le terme soit pas très joli
cette voiture balai de de de de la
rémunération est peut-être plus
concevable aujourd'hui on va terminer en
parlant des Jeux Olympiques puisque vous
allez faire partie des porteurs de la
femme je suis très heureux ou ouais
c'est un honneur ah immense immense
parce que le sport en France a mal été
déployé moi je fais partie de ces jeunes
gens dans ces quartiers qu'on appelle
maintenant politique de la ville où le
sport a été notre cadre éducationnel et
moi je remercierai jamais assez le monde
du judo et ces communes qui finalement
nous donnit une accisité au port au
sport gratuit et euh croyez-moi de
porter la flamme et je vais le porter au
nom de toutes ces personnes qui grâce au
sport ont un pu retrouver un petit pas
simplement devenir des athlètes de haut
niveau mais un peu retrouver une ligne
d'horizon dans les quartiers dans
lesquels on était vous savez déjà quel
va être le parcours de votre parcours
sur Bordeaux justement pour les Jeux
Olympiques c'est un enjeu énorme
évidemment pour l'hôtellerie
restauration est-ce qu'elle est prête
aujourd'hui non on a toujours ce ce ce
ce ce ce fil rouge des 2000 200000
postes à pourvoir on va monter à 230000
Postes à mon avis donc ça c'est très
compliqué en même temps il y a les
hôtels sont prêts j'ai quand même quatre
Olympiades à mon actif sera la 4e
olympiade et je me dis on va être sur
des taux d'occupation de 70 75 % ce qui
est très bien pour cette période donc
c'est un peu en tension c'est vrai mais
je je ne veux rester que positif sur les
Jeux Olympiques en France oui ça va être
difficile oui ça risque d'être compliqué
oui tout ne sera peut-être pas parfait
mais il faut défendre l'idée des Jeux
Olympiques en France c'est une une
aventure merveieux mais les chiffres les
indicateurs qui m'intéressent beaucoup
c'est l'après Jeux Olympiques j'ai
regardé toutes les Olympiades depuis
Barcelone finalement il y a une telle
prise d'image sur la ville sur le pays
dans lequel il y a les jeux et bien
l'après Jeux Olympiques et paralympi et
bien a une un élan pour le tourisme qui
est qui est très très bon donc voilà
soyons heureux de le faire ça ne va pas
être parfait ce sera sûrement compliqué
euh avec pe-être juste un un petit point
noir pour les gens qui veulent assister
au ces Jeux Olympiques c'est qu'il y a
une grosse crainte d'une augmentation
des tarifs et que les hôtels soient très
chers que les restaurants soient très
chers très très très honnêtement je n'y
crois pas du tout d'abord les les
hôteliers ont le y management comme ça
gère au fur et à mesure s'il y a une
finale oui les prix peuvent monter mais
regardez sur la Coupe du Monde mis à
part quelques fous qui ont fait quelques
excès globalement tout le monde s'est
tenu à des prix et à un moment donné on
peut pas reprocher aux entreprises
d'aller chercher du revenu vu que tout a
augmenté on peut pas dire aux gens vous
augmentez à ces entreprise 20 % de plus
pour votre charge rien simplement sur
l'énergie et n'augmentez pas vos prix à
un moment donné on ne tient pas donc à
un moment donné il faut respecter ça le
client n'est pas idiot le client
aujourd'hui a des alternatives qui nous
déplaisent beaucoup nous hôtelier c'est
le meublé touristique qui n'est
absolument pas contrôlé qui est vraiment
une niche fiscale aujourd'hui totalement
incontrôlée dans lequel les hôteliers on
sont vraiment dans une crainte là-dessus
parce que voilà des gens qui ne payent
pas de charge qui n'ont pas de norme et
on impose à des hôteliers une
surnormalisation de leurs entreprises
merci Thierry Marx merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin on
était ravi de vous recevoir on passe
tout de suite au club des territoires
merci